y'all last week was rough
[Music]
i feel like i was stuck in this i have
to be productive
but i don't want to do anything mood i
find myself in this place
regularly actually but it usually only
lasts for like a day or two
and then i'm back up on my feet but this
time
it was an entire two weeks maybe it was
yet another bout of pandemic blues
or the anticipation and adrenaline of
the new year was finally fizzing
or maybe mercury was in retrograde again
i don't know
but it was kind of rough trying to get
myself to do stuff when
literally all i wanted to do was curl up
into a blanket ball
and watch one piece it was a lot of
self-battle
a lot of self-doubt and wondering if
i was ever gonna feel like doing stuff
again i mean i even tried to hack it
i hung in and around my desk and put my
hands on my keyboard and sat in front of
my monitors because maybe
just maybe if i use my usual trick of
doing a 25 minute pomodoro timer to just
warm myself up to doing stuff because
mood follows action
i could finally kick off my engine
enough to be productive
and usually that's enough that literally
works like 90
of the time but not last week heck it
was the week that i plan to make a video
about how to stay motivated when coding
and doing stuff but how the heck was i
supposed to make a video like that when
i had
zero motivation for anything so yeah
that wasn't going to happen so i'm
making this video instead
so i guess it's kind of like a video
about how i think
productivity is overrated there's a lot
of things signaling to us from the world
this new
value of productivity my entire youtube
feed
instagram posts books i should have read
three years ago
and articles that get passed around
every twitter thread and
even my own videos through this
productivity or bust kind of mindset me
every time i connect to the internet
and i don't know i just realized that
like productivity is one of those values
we hold
high as an internet community and also
like productivity is
not a bad thing in and of itself and
it's good that things get done and we
move forward in our lives
and society and i also like that
productivity can mean many things
anything from writing that report for
that class
to taking a bath and taking care of
yourself because hashtag self-care
i guess what i'm trying to say is just
like doing anything
can be seen as productive but last week
i didn't want to do
anything all i wanted to do last week
was just sit in my room
bask in the sun like a plant and just
photosynthesize
i thought a lot about how productivity
at certain points in my life becomes a
curse
like it becomes how i measure my time on
earth
if i'm not doing something productive
it's not worth it somehow
and one day when i'm on my deathbed it's
like i'll have regretted not doing
more or something honestly it's a
mindset that i think i especially
started clinging to
when i started to work in tech where
every task is estimated
and committed to at the beginning of the
week well that's meant to be a system
for working on large-scale projects and
accountability
the other side of that coin was feeling
like my worth to the industry
was about how much i could get done and
like there's a moment last week where i
was so fed up with
not being productive and i was beating
myself up for it
and i was just like this is just
overrated
sometimes productivity helps me to get
important things done
and it gets me moving in other times it
makes me think that
just existing isn't good enough and
that's just dumb
so i realized over the course of the
week that you know what
it's okay to be unproductive i'm gonna
forgive myself
for being an absolute potato of a person
this week
because that's what my brain and body
are telling me to do
i didn't have any pressing deadlines or
things i absolutely needed to do
thank goodness so i decided to let
myself potato
but also not go full potato because i'm
too anxious to do that
and it'll make me feel like i'm floating
in space with nothing to hold on to
so there isn't really like a resolve to
this story it's really just kind of
about how i let myself potato and then i
don't know i just wanted to make a video
to like remind myself
that it's totally okay to be
unproductive the waves of life are gonna
rise and fall
and sometimes just sit completely still
and that's okay
because you gotta do you at your own
pace because oh my gosh maygo
you're not like your work or like the
amount of things that you
do you're you like you're you regardless
of those things
like you exist and that's okay and then
when you have the energy to get up
and do things again then do that and go
towards the direction that you want
because
girl you're not a machine for crying out
loud and every day
every week every month is not
necessarily going to be better than the
last
we need rest we need space we need
flexibility
and we need curiosity and wonder for our
lives
it's okay to be unproductive and it's
totally and
absolutely okay to be completely human
like i mentioned i think letting
yourself breathe and have space
is also about being able to explore your
creativity
which is where i wanted to thank the
sponsor of today's video
skillshare skillshare offers thousands
of inspiring classes for creative and
curious people
on topics including illustration design
photography
video freelancing and more most classes
are actually under 60 minutes with short
lessons to fit any schedule
they include a combination of video
lessons and a class project
it's curated specifically for learning
meaning there's no ads
and they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused and
follow wherever your creativity takes
you
and it's less than 10 a month with an
annual subscription
so maybe when you're feeling like an
absolute potato of a person next time
maybe you want to learn more about
productivity or
learn web development or maybe you want
to give your brain a break entirely and
learn something completely different
like learning guitar with the complete
beginner's guide so only the first
1000 of my subscribers to click the link
in the description
will get a free trial of premium
membership so you can explore your
creativity
thanks again to skillshare for
sponsoring thank you all so much for
watching the video i hope you enjoyed it
it's a week later and i'm feeling so
much better and so
yes it does get better i think after
being a potato for a little while
don't forget to subscribe because i'm
almost at 400k subscribers and i would
love for you to join the fam
and i'll see you next time take care
everybody